the process on the left of cancellation
as you started to talk about with the
perfect rhetorical Fortress the the
first step is
dismiss a person if they're just if you
can put a label of conservative on them
you can dismiss them in that way what
what other
efficient or what other effective uh
dismissal symptoms are there we have a
little bit of fun with uh uh with
demographic numbers I mean I run this by
height
um uh and I remember him being kind of
like I don't don't include the actual
percentage I'm like no we need to
include the actual percentages because
people are really bad at estimating what
what the demographics of the US actually
looks like both the right and the left
in different ways
um so we put in the numbers and we talk
about you know um being dismissed for
being white or being dismissed for uh
being straight or being dismissed for
being male
um and we uh and you can already dismiss
people for being conservative and we so
we we give examples in the book of of
these being used to dismiss people and
oftentimes on topics not related to the
fact that they are male or whether or
not they're minority and then we get to
I think it's like layer six and we're
like surprise guess what you're down to
point four percent of the population and
none of it mattered because if you have
the wrong opinion even if you're in that
point four percent of the most
intersectional person I've ever lived
lived and you have the wrong opinion
you're a heretic and you actually
probably will be hated even more and the
most interesting part of the research we
did for this was just asking
every prominent uh black conservative
and moderate that that we knew
personally have you been told that
you're not really black for an opinion
you had
every single one of them was like oh
yeah no and it's kind of funny because
it's like oftentimes white lefties
telling them that's like oh do you
consider yourself black John McWhorter
talked about having a reporter um when
he talked about when he showed that he
dissented from some of uh what he'd
described as kind of like woke racism in
his book woke ideas the reporter
actually is like so do you consider
yourself black he's like he was like
what are you crazy of course I do and
Coleman Hughes had one of the best
quotes on it he said I'm constantly
being told that the most important thing
uh to the how legitimate my opinion is
is whether uh whether or not I'm black
but then when I have a dissenting
opinion I get told I'm not really black
so perfect like there's there's no way
to falsify uh this argument
um that one really that investigation
really really struck me so and you lay
this out really nicely in the book that
there is this process of saying are you
conservative yes you can just dismiss
the person are you white this Mr person
are you male you can dismiss the person
there's these categories that make it
easier for you to dismiss a person's
ideas based on that and like you said
you end up in that tiny percentage you
can still dismiss and it's not just
dismissed we talk about this from a from
a practical standpoint the way the
limitations on you know reality and one
of them is time
um and a lot of cancel culture
um as as cultural norms as this way of
winning arguments without winning
arguments is about running out the clock
because by the time you get down to the
bottom of the uh of the or actually even
to get a couple steps into the perfect
Coral Fortress and you know where is the
time gone you know like
you probably just give up uh trying to
uh you know trying to actually have the
argument and you never get to the
argument in the first place and all of
these things are pretty sticky on social
media social media and practically
invented the perfect rhetorical Fortress
so that each one of those stages has a
virality to it yeah so it could it could
stick and it can get people really
excited it allows you to feel outraged
and superiority yeah because of that
that at the scale of the virality allows
you to never get to the actual
discussion of the point
um so but you know it's not just the
left it's the right sure also so
efficient rhetorical Fortress uh so
there something to be proud of on the
right it's more efficient yeah uh so you
don't have to listen to liberals and
anyone can be labeled the Liberals if
they have a wrong opinion I've seen
liberal and left and leftists all used
as a in the same kind of way yeah that's
leftist nonsense you don't have to
listen to experts yep even conservative
experts if they have the wrong opinion
you don't have to listen to journalists
even conservative journalists if they
have the wrong opinion and among the
mega Wing there's a fourth proposition
there's a fourth provision you don't
need to listen to anyone who isn't
pro-trump yeah and we call it efficient
because it it eliminates a lot of people
you probably should listen to at least
sometimes you know like we we point out
sometimes like how cancel culture can
interfere with faith and expertise so we
get kind of being a little suspicious of
experts but at the same time if you
follow that and you follow it
mechanically and I definitely you know I
think everybody in the US probably has
some older Uncle who exercises some of
these it is a really efficient way to
sort of show your uh to wall yourself
off from the rest of the world and
dismiss you know at least some people
you really should be listening to the
way you laid it out it made me realize
that we just take up so much of our
brain power
these things it's literally time we
could be solving things and you get like
you kind of exhaust yourself through
this process of being outraged based on
these labels and you never get to
actually
there's almost not enough time for
empathy for like looking at a person
thinking well maybe they're right
because you're so busy
categorizing them and it's what's the
fun and empathy and I mean what's so
interesting about this is that so much
um societal energy seems to be spent on
these nasty Primal desires where
essentially a lot of it's like please
tell me who I'm allowed to hate
where can I legitimately be cruel where
can I actually exercise some aggression
against somebody
um and it seems to sometimes be just
finding new justifications for that and
it's an understandable you know human
failing that sometimes can be used to
defend justice but again it will never
get you anywhere near the truth
uh one interesting case that you cover
about expertises with kovid yeah so how
did cancer culture come into play on the
topic of covet yeah I think that covid
was a big blow to people's faith and
expertise and cancel culture played a
big role in that
um I think one of the best examples of
this is Jennifer say at Levi's
um she is a lovely woman
um she was a vice president of Levi's uh
she talked about actually potentially
could be the president of Levi's jeans
and she was a big advocate for kids and
when they started shutting down the
schools she started saying this is going
to be a disaster this is going to hurt
uh the poor and disadvantaged kids the
most
um we have to figure out a way to open
the schools back up and that was such a
heretical point of view and the typical
kind of council culture uh wave took
over because he had all sorts of you
know petitions for her to be fired and
that she needed to apologize and all
this kind of stuff
and you know she was offered I think
like in a million dollar Severance which
you wouldn't take because she wanted to
tell the world what she thought about
this and and that she wanted to continue
saying
um that she hadn't changed her mind that
this was a disaster for young people and
now that's kind of the conventional
wisdom and the research is pretty it is
quite clear that this was devastating to
to particularly disadvantaged youth like
people understand this now as being okay
she was probably right but one of the
one of the really sad aspects of cancel
culture is people forget why you were
canceled and they just know they hate
you
um there's this lingering kind of like
well I don't have to take them seriously
anymore but by the way did you notice
they happened to be right on something
very important now one funny thing about
freedom of speech
freedom of speech wouldn't exist if you
didn't also have the the right to say
things that were wrong because if you
can't you know engage an idea for you if
you can't actually speculate you'll
never actually get to something that's
right in the first place but it's
especially galling when people who are
right were censored and you uh and never
actually got the credit that they
deserve